hey hello everybody and welcome to a
brand new video now a lot of you may be
familiar with my 1hour flipping
challenge uh today I thought I would mix
it up and do a 1our money-making
challenge so I might do some flipping
why not but this will include buying
items from shops uh maybe doing some
barrows I'm going do some set
combinations maybe I'll go combine some
mal addiction WS anything I can think of
that will make you money is fair game
and we're going to be starting with 40
mil today and 1 hour on the clock let's
get started so I always like to have one
thing ready when I start and the first
thing that I've noticed is that uh
tonight Fang can be combined into the
toxic blowpipe very easily and it looks
like it's selling for about
2750 and um we can buy it for about 2700
So that's a 50k combination well it's
not really a combination but it's a
crafting and now I'm using G tracker to
find the prices here they are a sponsor
of mine so go check them out they do
have a couple useful tools for finding
kind of weird flips like this or if you
want to call them flips or money makers
whatever um now I want to buy the F
quick so we're going to try buying it
for uh it says 2655 there I don't think
that's right let's try
2701 I'm kind of looking to instab buy
it uh cuz I'm not sure if that price is
going to stay up and the limit for this
is
five no didn't buy for 2700 So yeah that
price is pretty outdated
2715 and okay we instabot those perfect
uh so now what we're going to be doing
is just withdrawing a chisel from the
bank and deposit the Tanz night
fangs and wherever they went and all you
got to do is use the Chisel on there and
make the blow pipes really quick to do
three
four five also you theoretically get a
lot of crafting experience per power and
now we're going to go ahead and sell off
the toxic blow pipes and let's look on G
tracker here uh
let's try for
51 just for now so that's 13755 and we
bought them all for
13577 which is a nice easy 200k flip if
we actually do sell it for that price
anyway okay another nice quick uh kind
of flip to do is uh turning Willow seeds
into Willow saplings uh now it looks
like it has about a 740 GP margin on uh
which is okay um the uh toxic blow pipes
are coming through pretty quick they're
almost all the way done now I'll go buy
those cuz they will be pretty quick to
turn and the limit here is uh 200 so
it's not a huge investment anyway it's
only 2 mil and we could get about 140k
back which is pretty good all right we
got another uh tree combination we're
going to be doing here which is the
papaya tree seed uh another pretty cheap
one here that's a 900 GP margin on it so
about 180k we'll make off this uh which
I've gotten better before definitely but
still pretty good and we'll go down to
197 yeah sure that's fine and none of
the seeds have come through yet but they
are pretty quick to buy look nine
already for that okay so another easy
flip is the verox uh armor set
combination so what we're going to be
doing here is buying all the pieces and
then combining it back into its Set uh I
think this is the last flip I'm going to
leave in and then I'm go out and do a
couple other methods don't don't
directly involve the gr exchange um but
yeah so what we're going to do is just
look at all the prices here on e tracker
and put an offer in that seems
reasonable and then combine them all
into sets and sell them back on the
grand exchange okay so we pretty much
put all the pieces in the last one is
the Vero Helm uh which we're going to be
putting in for about uh
295 296 how about we're not trying to
get the best price cuz we are trying to
buy it uh pretty soon and a lot of our
offers have actually come through now
we've got five of the plat skirts three
or two of the flails and those need to
come through but all of the seeds came
through uh for the papaya tree and a lot
of the willow seeds come through uh so
we'll go ahead and combine those now and
we're going to pull this out cuz that
all sold as well so we got another 13
mil to work with here uh but yeah we'll
go ahead and combine at least all of the
one so I can show you now so first off
we have to combine the seeds like this
takes a little while but once I'm done
I'm going to be using the uh humidify
spell to water them which only take a
couple seconds uh which will be pretty
nice because otherwise you got to water
them with a watering can which is a bit
a pain in the ass but still doable but
we're going for the quickest possible
timer so we're going to use humidify
spell for sure okay so we're just
finishing up the seeds here I just
realized I will need to switch spell
books quickly which is okay it won't
take too long uh but that only took like
3 or 4 minutes to combine all of the
seeds into the pots uh so not too bad
okay so we just went to somebody's house
quickly here we're going to venerate in
the altar to go to lunar there we go and
then we're going to use the Ring of well
to teleport back to the Grand exchange
because we have no teleports anymore uh
but that's okay we shouldn't really need
them for the rest of the challenge but
if not we can always switch back it's
not too big a deal okay so now we're
ready to uh humidify our plants uh so
the papaya seedlings have all been
combined now it's really easy all we're
going to do is cast humidify it
humidifies every single one of them
perfect and then you put it back in the
bank and repeat this should only take uh
a minute at most you want to optimize
the amount of space in your inventory uh
unfortunately right now I don't have
the steam battle staff and um I have to
keep my cash with me or else I'm going
to get confused so you can shave off two
inventory slots from this okay that
should be the last inventory uh so now
all the P planes have been watered now
we just have to wait for them to grow
which will take two or three minutes
just in the bank and now if we have a
quick look at the gr exchange here uh
looks like almost all the willow seeds
have come through 46 more and that's
pretty much all of them now I'm just
going to quickly readjust the helm in
the uh brassard brassard sorry and then
we'll go ahead and combine the seeds
okay we're just finishing up adding the
seeds to the plants um to the planter
pot I should say and then we're going to
go ahead and humidify these ones as well
uh just go withdraw the runes and it
should only take another minute to
humidify okay there we go we H cast
humidify on all of them uh so we'll just
deposit those into the bank now if we
have a look at the willow seeds they're
still unwatered but if we look at the
papaya saplings they're saplings so that
means they're done and we can go ahead
and sell them off uh we'll just go
recheck the price here papaya
sapling and we're selling them for $
11994 and we bought the seeds for
11 11k pretty much so we're making the
900 GP profit on each one of these and
we're going to sell them for
11993 and hopefully these will sell off
relatively quickly
[Music]
11993 and that will be about a 180k
Profit just on that which I think is
pretty decent okay so we're just going
to wait around here until the other
saplin are turned or at least the
watered versions turned into the sapling
so now I'm going to go ahead and check a
couple potion decants now we're looking
for cheap potions cuz I want some money
left uh for the next method I'm going to
do uh which will require a good amount
of money uh so
293 and we'll hopefully buy them
for uh
$279 and energy potion 4 430 * 75 is 322
- 2 93 would be a 60k profit or 279 for
about a 80k profit or something like
that I'm just going to go ahead and buy
it for this price just cuz I want to be
pretty time efficient here am I going to
instab buy him not quite so in that case
I'm going to go ahead and redo the offer
okay so that will be an 80k profit once
we get it now let's go ahead and check
our bank here and looks like the perfect
the willow saplings have turned uh it
kind of sounds like I'm talking about a
zombie or something but now we'll go
ahead and look at the willow sapling and
we'll sell these off for 10 595 so it's
about a 140k profit there 10 595 looks
good and there we go we got everything
set so now the next method I'm going to
be doing is actually buying some items
from a shop now this one is one of my
favorite ones is buying from the ston
Mason shop in kigm so we're gonna have
to go deposit some of our items here
that we don't need okay we'll make sure
we got the Ring of wealth on us yeah so
what you need for this is only the giant
dwarf Quest completed and um you can
actually travel there just through this
trap door here which is nice okay so
here we are so we're in cigm now from
here we have to go over to the west side
of the city kind of to the completely
opposite side and I don't think we want
in here we're just going to go around it
so what the stone Mission shop has is
higher level construction items now what
you're going to be looking for is the
gold leaf well really any of these three
but probably not the Magic Stone right
now cuz that's too expensive you can see
the gold leaf sells for routinely 4K
more than it does in the shop uh the
marble block looks like it's almost 7K
more so it's also worth checking what
the ratio is to see which one's actually
more efficient if you had infinite money
of course you'd go for just the best
margin but that rarely is the case uh so
we're going to go ahead and just check
the items on G tracker uh while I run
there okay so we got the gold leaf
openers this one sells for 130 in the
shop and looks like we could sell it for
about
136 uh which is really nice the marble
block uh sells
for 220 or 325 and could sell for 334
now the gold leaf is overall just better
right now the only reason I would do
both is because it would increase th
rate that they're going to sell at uh so
I'll consider it let's go ahead and jump
in here it's right here just just south
to the bank so it's even close to a bank
which is nice so what you have to do
trade him uh buy a one of each because
once you go past that it becomes too
expensive and then you're going to hop
worlds and then repeat so it's a lot of
world hopping but it's really not too
bad every four or five worlds you kind
of have to stop for a second and make
sure that your client can catch up
otherwise it'll start booting you out of
the game which is pretty annoying I
think in this case I'm going to be
buying both because I think I don't have
enough time to just stay here without
long but if you imagine each one is a 7K
profit that is a almost a 15K profit per
world and I'm hopping through these
worlds really quick here okay so I
noticed here in my sidebar that you can
actually see here that all of the
verac's armor pieces came through it
also appeared in my
chat I know where went anyway they're
done uh so we're going to take this
opportunity to let our world hopping
cool down a little bit and we'll go back
to the gr exchange and uh readjust those
offers since they're through and we can
go ahead and combine all them
okay so we can go ahead and collect
everything here uh so we got five of
each armor piece I could have maybe gone
for more but I don't actually know how
long it's going to take to come through
why do we have 10 ver Helms oh my that's
no good okay so it looks like I am going
to be going for 10 now cuz I already
bought 10 of the other piece uh my bad
so we'll go ahead and well we inst
bought 10 Vero bards that kind of
simplifies things and we'll go ahead and
buy another five of the plate bodies or
plate skirts sorry uh which we did iny
earlier
not this time though and five more of
the
flails jeez okay there we go well that
brings us down a little bit more money
which is fine uh so for now we'll go
ahead and just combine the five uh sets
right here and combine the five and
start selling those off at least and
we're going to be selling them for
unfortunately they're down to about 1820
so we'll sell those off hopefully we
could have sold them for more but well
let's try 18 30 for now because
otherwise it's a pretty low margin which
kind of sucks okay guys that's pretty
much all our money invested here we're
going to buy one more gold leaf one more
marble block and uh we don't have enough
for this do we no uh we'll leave that
money just in case we need it to price
check something and there we go we'll
head back to the Grand exchange now and
readjust our offers and see what has
come through and what has not uh so now
for organ exchange we have the gold
leaves already sold I mean 3K on the
gold leaves isn't awful but uh still it
could have been better uh we have the
marble blocks slowly coming through uh
for a 5k profit so we'll go ahead and
withdraw the rest of our blocks and
leaves uh so the gold leaf I'm going to
check again just for the sake of hoping
the price has changed uh 134 I guess
that is an extra K actually so that's
worth checking all right so we're going
to get about 100K off of that once
that's sold which is nice uh the marble
block I don't think there's any point of
rechecking it's either gone down if
anything
9999 this pretty much
330 perfect and we have all the plate
skirts coming through and four of the
five flails and unfortunately none of
the sets have actually sold off so we'll
have to go readjust that okay we just
bought the last flail outright so we can
go ahead and start selling them uh set
and we'll actually need to bank this
last one they all have to be noted or
unnoted
uh so get a sets and verac now we have
10 verac sets and got 10 minutes left so
I think it's important to actually price
check this and we'll sell it off with it
so for 1824 we can sell them for so
we'll sell these back for 18 23999
that's pretty much what we had and went
at so that's uh well let's see what the
profit is on that okay so we're looking
at about 220k on those a little better
than I thought they were going to be but
still not as good as these flips
normally are so now we have 10 minutes
left I think I'm just going to do uh
maybe two barrels runs and then call it
a day okay so we're just finishing up
the first run here it's a 4 minutes 50
seconds now I would have enough to
finish the next run but I ran out of
darts in my stupid blowpipe uh so I'll
go see if I can actually redo that in
time 10 seconds left we didn't quite get
it unfortunately but we're pretty close
and actually a bunch of things sold off
right before the Finish which is pretty
nice uh so we'll just finish up this
bars run and then we go back and check
on the grand exchange okay so our final
Bears chest is going to be an item that
would be amazing oh my God we got a
verax brard not very valuable but
actually a lot of runes too so that's
pretty good and now we'll head back to
the Grand exchange still an item uh
which is nice not a valuable one though
okay so we're back at the Grand exchange
and that was actually a lot closer to
selling everything off than I thought it
would be so we'll go ahead and start
pulling out these offers here H Magic
Stone sold for 3K profit not right there
all the marble blocks sold for a 5k
profit which is pretty nice the gold
leaves all sold for a 4K
profit um so we'll go ahead and start
just dumping our Bears rewards in here
which was actually extremely good for
two runs the runes alone were pretty
good and drop those in and the
brassard for 193k sure 195 + 117 plus 37
K just for two runs is pretty nice it's
about 320k or something like that okay
so we'll come back when all this stuff
is sold off probably just be another 5
or 10 minutes and we'll go look at how
much money we ended up making all right
guys so everything is sold off um we had
to readjust the papayas sa planes but it
wasn't too bad so let's go ahead and
claim all of the offers and see how much
money we made in 1 hour claim that claim
these guys here and of course the rock
armor sets bring us up to 41 mil as we
we did make at least 1 mil let's go have
a
look okay looks like we made 1.3 mil in
an hour uh not bad for our first attempt
I know I can do better than this uh we
didn't get too lucky on the armor set
combinations plus I [__] up a little
bit so I think I'm going to try this
again sometime my ultimate goal is to
try to make 10 mil in 1 hour not sure if
that's going to be possible think if I
have enough money it'll be possible but
anyway guys I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did uh don't forget to the video
like and I will see you guys in the next
[Music]
episode